we work as a great team so Jill Dillard
sharing some rare PDA with her hubby
it's good to have at least like a little
bit of time each day I don't know what
like the normal like good amount is
maybe like 15 minutes or so of laughing
together or doing something fun together
Jill part of the Duggar family posted
this photo on Instagram kissing her
husband Derek Dillard the caption I'm so
incredibly grateful for my man his
support means the world to me I think
anything yeah to like build up your
marriage and your relationship is
helpful the post comes as Jill prepares
to reveal more secrets about growing up
in her famous family in her upcoming
Memoir counting the cost a lot of times
you have to go through hell because it's
not until then that you would risk
everything to like get out of those
situations this following Jill and
Derek's appearance on the Prime video
docu-series Shiny Happy People Duggar
family secrets there's a story that's
going to be told and I would rather be
the one telling it it's been five years
since the couple left the Duggar
family's popular TLC series 19 Kids and
Counting and the spin-off counting on
and have been very open about their
decision to set themselves apart from
her family we left the show because
basically our family goals that we had
for ourselves didn't align with what we
found out that like we we ended up
finding out like we didn't have as much
control over
um our lives as it related to like the
show and stuff in the docu-series Jill
opened up about allegations that Jim Bob
and Michelle emotionally and physically
abused their children yes we were taken
advantage of well I don't like talking
about it
um the four-part series also features
Jill's cousin Amy King who was also on
19 Kids and Counting is retaliation at
all a fear of yours I'm not afraid
anymore
I am gonna speak up for those that can't
speak did you see your cousins being
punished
they called it encouragement they
literally said you need to come into the
room and we need to give you some
encouragement the iblp is a cult people
just saw it as like just a way of living
and to be more you know a little more
conservative but they never saw the
abuse that took place ask for Jules
potential return to reality TV we don't
regret leaving the show we feel like it
was the best thing for our family right
now we have no plans to like join back
into the show or anything
foreign